Daniel: Welcome,
Raf, also co author on the paper.
Raf: So how are you doing?
I'm good.
What about you?
Daniel: Pretty good.
Other than this brief interval of white
light, I'm just hanging out.
Raf: Fantastic.
So I'm trying to figure out here how I
can.
I'm using a different slide software, so
I need to make sure that I can pull this
up in the right way.
So give me just a quick second.
Daniel: Yeah, great.
Raf: Cool.
Daniel: So just just to read off what's
coming while you figure that out.
So right now we have Ralph Kaufman, and
this presentation is going to be Gaia, an
active powered network for planetary
scale sense making.
Following this 30 minutes presentation,
we'll have Avel Gwynen Carlo on embedded
Normativity.
That looks perfect.
That's perfect.
Raf: Awesome.
Daniel: All right.
Thanks, Raf, to you.
Raf: Thank you.
All right, I was going to try to see if I
could blow this up to full screen, but.
Daniel: I got it on the stream.
Looks good on the stream.
Go for it.
Raf: Cool.
So I'm just pulling up my notes here.
All right, so let me just test that this
moves.
Did I just move the slide?
Great.
Cool.
All right, so as I said, hi, everyone.
It's a huge pleasure to be here and thank
you so much to Daniel and everybody else
in the Institute for organizing this.
I'm going to talk about what I think is
the single most important application of
active entrance.
Not as a detriment to the others, but it'
's sort of upstream of everything else.
And that is how do the 8 billion of us
humans make sense of what's going on in
our planet and all scales?
And how do we use that understanding to
survive as a species?
So this presentation here is a bit of a
technical presentation and it has a lot
of content.
It's going to move pretty fast and assume
that you're familiar with some concepts,
but I'm going to try to leave time for Q
A at the end.
So first of all, I'm going to talk about
the motivation behind what we're doing,
in particular the concepts of the meta
crisis and the third attractor.
Then I'll give an overview of our network
architecture and the application so far
and cover the many remaining challenges.
And last but not least, I plan to
convince you that this is the single most
important thing you could ever be working
on.
And I'm doing this because we need your
help.
So that's a taster of what we have.
As I said, let's jump right into it with
the motivation.
And what greater motivation could there
be?
If you haven't heard of the metacrisis,
it's a term that it's originally from
Doctor Who, but it was borrowed by
thinker called Daniel Schmuckenberger to
talk about the total risk for humanity
and the biosphere that is posed by the
combination of three factors.
The first being the increasing
interconnectedness of everything from
climate to food security to national
security.
To biodiversity and everything in between.
.
The second being the risks associated
with self evolving technology, including
runaway artificial intelligence and the
third being the increasing omnipresence
of coordination failures personified as
the god of coordination failures moloch.
And so the combination of these three
factors as hypothesized by
Schmuckenberger will lead to either one
of two attractors, one of them being
chaotic breakdown of all structure and
the second being a reversal to oppressive
authoritarian control.
And obviously both of those qualify as
that in my book, I assume in yours as
well.
So the question of course is can we
actually find a third attractor that is
positive sum as opposed to negative sum?
And rather the question is can we design
it?
So what I claim, and what we as the Guy
Consortium claim, is that yes we can and
we can design this attractor.
The design goal is basically to build
resilience and stabilization into our
biosocial economic system and to do this
subject to multilevel system constraints
like the planetary boundaries
desirability, meaning it has to be
something that people actually want so
they will help it happen.
So it needs to preserve standards of
living and so on.
And it needs to be feasible, it needs to
be achievable from our current initial
conditions.
And of course there's a lot of design
complicators in the mix, some of which
partial observation, there's a lot of
information asymmetry going on, there's a
lot of uncertainty about how the pieces
of the world system work from a
scientific perspective, there's obvious
computability constraints associated to
this.
And last but not least, you can't really
control what happens.
In most cases we can only create
incentives, recommendations and nudges.
So easy, right?
Of course it's not easy, but we think we
can do it if we apply the sum of the
principles from cybernetics that we
already know and apply them in a
decentralized positive sum composable way.
.
So what we're talking about here is
decentralized network, a decentralized
hybrid AI human network for planetary
scale decision support and automation.
It recognizes that we will have human and
artificial agents interacting by the
billions in an open network.
Its goal is to facilitate both
continuance or model alignment and
coherence or goal alignment at multiple
levels or scales up to the global scale,
meaning the survival of the system as a
whole.
It will need to feature built in
incentives and governance and it will
need to be privacy preserving,
intrinsically.
So the below listed participants are
participants, founders of the consortium.
.
I'm going to talk about it later.
So this is the framing, this is the
motivation for what we're doing.
And now I'm going to give a whirlwind
tour of the architecture so far and I'm
going to cover mostly what we've built,
the version of this architecture that we'
've built so far, thinking about this
explicitly.
And then I'm going to talk about how this
connects to other architectures that
already exist in the world, just very
briefly.
So we've been framing this as an
architecture for building decentralized
digital twins, which are local models of
real world systems that run in network.
And the role that such digital twins play
is that they help us understand the costs
and benefits of strategies and projects
that happen in the real world.
And in our organization, Digital Gaia, we
started out caring primarily about
agroecology.
So how do you actually make better
decisions, meaning better recommendations,
, negotiations, valuations, investments
into a farm, into a forest, into bio
landscape, to make it better, to make it
more likely to survive and thrive.
So, as practical implementation, it needs
to tackle several real world challenges.
First of all, it needs to handle
distributed, non IID data.
Data is sparse.
It's heterogeneous, it's private, it's
potentially unreliable.
It needs to enable localized
collaborative forecasting and planning,
personalized planning and privacy
preserving.
It needs to accept the fact that it won't
be able to directly control, but only
recommended nudge, as we discussed.
And the outline of what we came up with
is this concept of the Guy Network, which
is a mesh of AI agents called natural
entities, or Ants for short, that act as
proxies for real world systems.
Each ant runs on an engine called Tengor,
which it uses to inquire, learn, plan,
and allocate resources.
And ants communicate in a language called
the Guy Protocol.
They use this language to independently
interact with their environments and each
other.
And if we do this right I'll show a bit
more of this later, but if we do this
right, the Guy network's behavior
approximates a single composite agent
that handles, that interacts with and
couples with its global environment.
Cool.
So just to give you an overview of how
this works under the hood, the Fangor
engine is really the heart of our
architecture.
And the core loop that is mentioned here
is a typical active inference loop.
But to make this work in very
heterogeneous and distributed context,
there's lots of work involved.
So just some highlights that I think are
going to be particularly interesting for
this crowd.
First of all, so as I said, the same core
engine needs to be able to work for very
heterogeneous contexts.
So each agent has access to a library of
generative models.
And these models are specified using a
Python based probabilistic programming
DSL, and they declare what context they'
're appropriate for using a shared
ontology.
Using that ontology, Fangorn can then
select the most appropriate model to use
online, given the configurations, like
project configurations and the kinds of
observational data available.
So using a model that's appropriate for
farm or for forest, what kind of farm,
what kind of forest, what kind of
ecosystem, what kind of their context
energy project I'm going to get into the
examples right now because there's more
on the applications later on.
So we end up with a network of
heterogeneous agents, but that's okay.
They actually form a single model in a
formal sense because they're all
connected hierarchically by a system of
hyperparators.
And this means that Fangor needs to
support inference of generic hierarchical
generative models.
And we actually do this automatically
using approximate posteriors with
structural constraints.
And so we have this global model that
connects all the nodes and describes
general facts that apply over multiple
contexts.
And this means the whole network needs to
jointly perform inference over this
global model using a peer to peer or
federated algorithm.
So initially the way this works is
initially the network sets the global
posterior to be the same as the global
prior.
Each node then independently performs
local optimization of the variational
free energy and then passes the
parameters of the new global solution to
the peers in the network where they use
it as a hyperprior.
And this works over a broad range of
topologies and under pretty general
constraints.
And by the way, I'd like to mention that
there's a lot of overlap and interaction
between the stuff that I'm talking about
here and some of the other presentations
that you're seeing today and I wasn't
able to reference them explicitly in this
talk, but I'm sure you're going to see
the connections cool.
So what it turns out is that the shared
parameters that represent our global
model are effectively stored by the
network stored in a federated parameter
store, meaning that each node stores
their own local parameters, they're
private stuffed about their own local
context and multiple nodes store copies
of the global parameters.
And this architecture, because it
supports heterogeneous local models, it
actually allows us to introduce another
kind of nodes which we call ant mood
nodes.
These are nodes that aggregate scientific
and empirical information using a meta
analysis model.
And we actually are able to use that meta
analysis model to constrain our project
level models or ants using quote unquote
imported knowledge that wasn't directly
observed by them, which is left to right
in this picture.
But this actually also goes two ways.
So empirical findings from the project,
what actually works on the ground for
this particular project also informs the
ant modes posteriors which is the right
to left.
And so we actually have a complete cycle
of science and empirics all implemented
using hierarchical active inference.
So finally, just among the global
parameters that network learns by
federated inference are the precisions
associated with data coming from the
different data providers.
And this gives each node a way to consume
data without trusted ground truth and
basically to learn together which sources
they can rely on it for what?
This is just some of more core features.
We're working on integrating many other
capabilities into this architecture.
Not going to go through all of this, but
basically what we're finding is that we
have all the building blocks to turn this
into a full feature decision network
complete with its own internal knowledge
economy, meaning that contributions get
attributed and rewarded in proportion to
the free energy reduction that they
afford.
Cool.
So, jumping into applications, as I
mentioned, our main focus as an
organization has been on modeling
agroecological projects like regenerative
agriculture and agroforestry.
And this exercises all the constraints
that we've talked about so far.
So again, I'm not going to go into full
detail, but just to give an overview of
what is the anatomy of generative model
for a farm or forest.
So start at the bottom right with
observables that are things that we can
measure about that ecosystem, about that
local context like the plant count and
size, vegetation indices from satellite
data and so on.
These are linked to latent states which
form a nonlinear dynamical system that's
parameterized by the policy the the
things that modulate the latent states
like agricultural interventions and
practices.
You can think of the timing of planting
and harvesting, what kinds of crops or
trees get planted, what products like
pesticides get applied or not, and more
as well as covariates.
So external events like weather, physical
risks, wildfire, drought and so on.
And so there's some scientific and
measurement parameters that go into this
as well.
Things like the effect sizes of the
various actions and covariance.
And these local parameters are
conditionally dependent on a set of
global parameters which, as we discussed,
they link information between different
ends and different sources of knowledge.
The same global parameters are used in
the meta analysis model and they actually
establish the link between what is found
to happen on the ground and what is
reported in the literature.
I'm not going to go into this because I
think I'm going to run a bit long, but
basically the concept is that we have
these project nodes that correspond to
many farms and they're each on
independent nodes in the network that are
also connected to this common
metaanalysis model.
And together these nodes, they
incorporate academic studies, expert
knowledge and locally relevant context.
They do so privately, so only processing
the local data locally and through this
parameter sharing they actually jointly
and iteratively estimate the global
posterior in a cycle forever, for as long
as there is new data about the project,
as long as there's new studies and new
expert knowledges.
So all of this is happening basically in
an online way.
And again, the topology can vary, but the
principles remain the same.
So, just to show a little bit of how this
works, this is just two epochs of the
global posteriors and this is just
location and scale for two parameters the
slope and the intercept of the
relationship between a vegetation index
and the tree biomass in one given hectare
of forest.
And as you can see, this converges pretty
quickly.
It's comparable to local only methods.
And just to highlight how this can be
used, also the limits of how this can be
used to estimate source reliability.
Here's a really successful example at the
left.
It's pretty straightforward to use this
to estimate reliability of satellite data.
.
And for other cases, like very local,
very context specific data, you actually
need more data or more data from more
independent sources that we had in this
demo here.
Another very useful use case of this is,
as we discussed, we don't have direct
control over what happens at a form.
We can only recommend and nudge often.
We also like a node gets sued up, gets
sued up for an existing project that has
already happened and we want to find out
what actions were taken in the past.
And the same generative model can be used
to estimate what happened in the past.
In this example, it infers when planting
started and when harvests started for
different fields.
So bringing it all together.
One of the applications that we've been
using, we've been working on it actually
uses all this machinery together to
validate claims about projects
performance and to estimate future
performance.
We've deployed this in real world
projects.
The examples here in this photo are by
are relevant to Agroforestry farms in
Colombia.
And we found that this actually helps the
project developers and their funders to
come to a shared understanding of how
successful the project is, how much it's
worth in terms of its impact and its
fundability, whether it should be scaled
up or needs to change course.
What is the quality of the strategy
versus other potential strategies for
natural regeneration and so on?
So it's actually useful on the ground for
decision making in this context.
Cool.
So finally I want to talk about the end
state and going back to our original
motivation of solving everything.
I forgive you for your thinking.
This is nice.
But hey, we've been kind of in this
downward spiral towards the metacrisis
for a long time and what you're telling
me doesn't even come close to solving
everything.
And you're right, there's a lot of moving
pieces that need to be built and
connected.
But here's the good news.
We can do this.
There's no mystery here and we don't need
perfection.
I love this quote from Edward Fulbrook
that says that to define a policy, we don'
't need exact empirical measures or
optimality, if one jumps from an airplane,
, it may be nice to have an ultimate, but
what one really needs is a parachute.
So there is only so much that we can get
in terms of diminishing returns.
What we should be refocusing on is
creating and refining solutions
everywhere and connecting them everywhere.
.
And you might be thinking about how does
this actually scale to global goals and
how does this actually get used for
scalably building into the fabric of
decisions in our society.
So about scaling to global goals, I again
won't be able to get into the details,
but maybe Connor mentioned this in his
presentation earlier.
We have actually some proof of concepts
that we can actually build active agents
that are made of active agents.
So we've shown in this paper here that a
collective of interacting active agents
is able to perform approximate inference
at the ensemble level.
And that this further that this happens
through specific mechanisms that are
mediated by cognitive capabilities like
theory of mind and goal alignment.
They work together to improve collective
performance by eliminating ambiguity
through actively exploiting diversity.
So that's one.
And the other question is how do we
actually build this kind of stuff into
not just these ad hoc decisions, but into
really the fabric of decision making that
is our global economic system.
So, talking about here work that I did
with Casper Hesp, this is a game that
highlights the ability of ants just like
the ones that we just described to infer
true system state and use it to credibly
incentivize long term positive outcomes
in an externality happy scenario.
This theme we were able to show that it
works even with adversarial bot
strategies and even with high uncertainty
and intentional misinformation.
So you can actually get these ends to
work with budgets and incentives to drive
decision making that internalize
externalities and compensates for
collusion and generates long term
positive outcomes.
That's not all.
There are other solutions that have been
around for longer than ours that apply
similar principles to global decision
making problems in the real world at
scale.
This is one case study from our partners
at Cognizance that they developed for the
COVID pandemic and this is not using
Active infrastormalism.
This is a combination of traditional
recurrent neural networks for prediction
and evolutionary optimization for
prescription.
And it's actually able to achieve some
pretty amazing stuff.
It discovers a pareto front between
prevention of cases and economic cost.
It's also a showcase for hybrid human AI
intelligence.
They did an initial version of this model,
, then they launched an XPRIZE, they got
a bunch of contributions for other models
and then they did a meta model that
discovered a better pareto front and even
better.
This tool has actually been used to
advise policy in the real world.
So it's actually very exciting that we're
working with them and connecting the dots,
, because we need to connect the dots, we
need to bring it all together.
This illustration here is just, I think,
a subset of the effects of the climate
change crisis, which is just one aspect
of the metacrisis on humans, on our
society and the economy.
And so we actually need to be able to
deploy solutions that work across many
different domains and to connect these
dots.
This means two things.
The first is interoperability aligning
decisions across context so that we don't
get unintended consequences.
And second is reusability so being able
to transport and transfer learning and
structure across contexts.
So for instance, using that evolutionary
approach from the COVID example in our
agricultural context or in many other
possible contexts, and this takes the
form of libraries, of components, APIs
and so forth.
So that's what we're working on.
So we're launching this consortium.
We just put up the website a few minutes
ago, and we have the goal of having a
minimal but functionally complete
implementation by the end of next year.
And this is an open project.
We are working on this at our
organization called Digital Guy, but we'
're also launching this open consortium
that welcomes contributors from anywhere,
both active inference experts and non
experts.
And we need a lot of contributors.
We need all of you because this is the
most important thing that we could ever
be working on together.
And we need your help to tackle the many
remaining challenges.
So if you want to help us build the
planetary brain, please go to
Gaiaconsortium.org or reach out to me.
You know where to find me.
And together we can design, build, and
learn what it takes to achieve planetary
regeneration.
Thank you.
Daniel: Barath.
Thanks for the great presentation.
I'll post the link to Gaia Consortium
into the YouTube live chat.
But let me get a few quick questions in.
So here we go.
First question.
This is from Marco Lynn.
I agree with the critical importance of
such a project.
How will you deal with the challenges of
scaling given the dependence on real
world entities like humans, dependence on
real world entities like humans for major
metacrisis domains such as geopolitics,
sociocultural fragmentation, and other
particularly hard sense making domains?
Raf: First of all hi, Marco.
Yeah, thanks for the question.
And I 100% agree that I'm not claiming
that this is sufficient.
I'm just claiming that it's necessary.
We do have a lot of ideas and a lot of
energy that we want to put into exactly
what you described, how to weave what we'
're doing into the existing incentive
landscapes, whether they're market
incentives or policy incentives.
But ultimately, this needs to be an
enabler.
This needs to meet people where they are.
.
And we need to be cognizant that change
is not going to happen overnight, at
least not right now.
Right.
Typically these things take a while to
mature and then they snap into place.
And we're already finding some of this
happening in some of the domains that we'
're working on where nothing happened for
a very long time and then bam, hockey
stick.
And we believe that the same can happen
pretty much anywhere.
So we're very optimistic.
Daniel: Great.
What are currently the greatest
challenges for Gaia as an organization?
I love that kind of ambiguous question,
like, is that the Gaia Consortium as an
organization or is it Gaia?
But let's hear both.
What are the greatest challenges or
frictions for the Consortium and for the
bigger picture.
Raf: Going to I'm not going to talk about
the technical stuff for change.
I'm going to talk about the more meta
stuff.
And it's actually very related to what
your previous presentation, Daniel, about
that paper about the Institute talked
about.
And it's really related to building out
this common, what we were calling the
common cognitive kernel for sense making
and decision making and relatedly
breaking through this culture of sort of
suspicion and surf wars and getting
people trying to stake their claim to
something.
So we are, and always have been extremely
open, but it's kind of hard anyway to
build trust.
So we're aware that it's going to take a
while to build this trust with everybody.
.
And I think the only answer to that is
really to be as participatory and
transparent as possible.
Also being humble and knowing where we
don't have the answer and asking people
to help us.
Daniel: Awesome.
Any closing words or thoughts?
Raf: Well, if there are no further
questions, again, I thank you all for
paying attention and I'm going to be
reaching out a lot more.
You're going to hear a lot more about
this consortium.
As I said, it was just formed.
They just put up a website in time for
this presentation.
By the way, thanks so much to Mahi and of
course, Steve and everybody else who's
been part of forming and getting this
ball to start rolling.
We are very early stage, very formative,
and still very client.
So I just gave you my perspective on a
bunch of these things, the shape of it
that has come from our work on this so
far, and even not all of it.
Just a piece that we could cover in 20
minutes or so.
But we are very plural.
We want to engage with you on different
paths, forward, different opportunities
to build things, to experiment, to
connect the dots, to learn together.
And ultimately, we really just want to
provide a platform, a convening space, a
protocol in the classic sense of the
world, a word of a shared language, a
shared means of communication, a shared
means of understanding, to find together
what we need to do to actually build this
third attractor.
Daniel: Awesome call Gaia trim tab.
Raf: Thank you exactly.
Thanks so much, Daniel, and see you guys
soon.
Daniel: Bye bye.
All right.
What a cool presentation.